hi there in this video I'll show you
some tips and tricks to help you prepare
your image data in cloud Auto and I'll
vision although I'll be showing Auto ml
vision here the concepts I'll be showing
applied to auto ml natural language as
well for this walkthrough we'll be
building a model to detect the type of
cloud in an image because there's no
better place to analyze clouds than the
cloud I've got five possible labels each
corresponding with a different type of
cloud there are many ways to add labeled
images to your auto ml vision data set
in this video I'll show you how to do
the following first will upload labelled
images directly from our computer then
we'll review image labels and add
additional images in the auto ml vision
UI the cloud images on my computer are
organized into folders for each label
using this approach I can create a zip
file of these folders and when I upload
the zip to Auto ml it will use the
folder names to automatically assign
labels to each image for example this
image of a cirrus cloud will get the
Cirrus label assigned since it's in that
folder I'll create the zip now I've
already enabled Auto ml vision for this
project and created my data set so next
let's upload this zip file of labelled
images note that auto ml vision has a 30
megabyte file size limit for larger data
sets you can either create multiple zip
files or upload your images to Google
Cloud storage and create a labeled CSV
with all of my labeled images uploaded
it's time to review them in the auto ml
vision UI here I can look at all of the
images assigned to a specific label to
make sure they're labeled correctly
looking at the Cirrus images it seems
like this one is incorrectly labeled I
can click on it and switch it to the
correct label cumulonimbus since I
created my label dataset some of my
friends heard about this project and
sent over a few of their own cloud
images to be used in training let's add
them from the all images tab I can
select add images and then upload from
your computer
notice that because I uploaded these
from the all images tab they went into
the unlabeled category I can click on
unlabeled to go in and add labels to
these images one of my friends is a
cloud expert and send me images
specifically of cirrus clouds I can
apply that label to them directly by
clicking on Cirrus and then adding the
images now that I've got all of my
images uploaded let's explore what I can
do with the image selection tool I can
click the check mark here to select all
images on a page or I can select
individual images by clicking on the
check box on the top left of an image
with images selected I can move them to
the unlabeled category by clicking on
label and then unlabeled ease images
will still be in my data set and will
remain in cloud storage but because they
don't have a label they won't be used in
training to delete an image for my
dataset entirely and from Google Cloud
storage I can select it and then press
Delete
there are also some handy label ordering
tools on the left if I click on the menu
bar here I can choose how I want to
order my labels I can order them
alphabetically or if I want to see where
I need to add more images I can sort
from fewest to most remember that you
need at least 10 images per label to
train a model in auto ml vision to start
gathering images of a new cloud type I
can add the label here and start
importing images for it now that I've
uploaded all my images and labeled them
correctly I can export the data set to a
cloud storage directory this will create
a CSV file with details on whether an
image was included in the training test
or validation data set its Google Cloud
Storage URL and its corresponding label
this is useful if I want to share the
data set with others on my team or see
how my dataset was split for training
and testing with all my images uploaded
and labeled I'm ready to train my model
the great thing about Auto ml is that I
don't need to worry about writing any of
the code from my model all I need to do
is click a button to train it that's all
for now stay tuned for future videos to
cover more Auto ml features
[Music]